why am i handcuffed to this briefcase
what is the significance of this floppy
disk inside a hamster ball wait what's
this yeah that makes absolutely no sense
what's going on the new roller before I
go to sleep got me thinking about memory
loss in movies see it stars Nicole
Kidman is a woman who was nearly beaten
to death and suffers from anti
retrograde amnesia every morning she has
to be reminded of who she is she's
trying to figure out who attempted to
kill her and she's not sure who she can
trust right I am sold even if I didn't
know that this was adapted from a highly
acclaimed novel I'm there it's actually
vaguely plausible anti retrograde
amnesia is a real thing a rare but not
unheard of condition and high-concept
movies about amnesia generally have a
pretty good track record the plot device
fares much better in movies and on TV
shows where one bump on the head
instantly causes memory loss and another
bump on the head
instantly cures it like clockwork that
is pure unadulterated psychological
poppycock hey does anyone have a 3.5
inch disk drive I can borrow what's this
on the label I am still so confused
anyway so many great thrillers have used
amnesia as a plot device Total Recall
inception memento spellbound Manchurian
Candidate Bourne Identity memory loss is
the perfect movie melody because it puts
the protagonist on the same footing as
the viewer with no pre-existing
knowledge of what's going on
you have to piece things together
alongside of them that makes it so much
easier for the audience to identify with
the plight of the character on screen
even if it's Nicole Kidman oh now I get
it enter the issue lead is lead speak
for Leach and the character leach first
appeared in uncanny x-men number 179 so
if I enter 179 man I hope the movie has
a better payoff than that and Asia isn't
just a good plot device for mysteries it
even worked in rom-coms like 50 first
dates an eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind what's your favorite
amnesia movie mine isn't let me know
you're picking the comments and
subscribe to the wired Channel